foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships it's a show
about your life and your money Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
life and money open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five CJ is starting off this
hour in Chicago hi CJ how are you
hi thanks for taking my call guys sure
what's up
so um I'm 38 years old my wife's 34.
um we haven't uh our take-home income is
about 120 000 a year and
I've been well we've been working on um
paying off fifty seven thousand dollars
in debt
um for the last six months or so and my
wife she's six months pregnant
um
so I've just been kind of saving money
since we found out and come to find out
uh she racked up fifty thousand dollars
in credit card debt that I wasn't aware
of and I'm terrified and I don't know
what to do
in the last six months
um no this is actually been going on for
longer than that um I think it got worse
since she became pregnant buying baby
stuff and I don't know what all has gone
through her head
um but
yeah I'm scared
okay let me let me make sure I get the
entire picture Okay
um she knew
and you two were having conversations
that you're trying to pay off fifty
seven thousand dollars in debt
yes and they're watching to do that
meantime she's buying things
and so she was lying to you
Yeah by not telling me she was lying
yeah wow purposefully hiding it that's
like deception correct yeah terrified's
probably not the right word to describe
your emotions
yeah that's that's accurate
um
when you okay confronted her what what
happened
um she immediately came clean and
started crying and she I mean she feels
bad about it she knows she was in the
wrong
um
I I told her that you know I can forgive
her if she picks right steps to
clean this up with me and I mean with
her being about to have a baby in a few
months I told her
um
I will work as much overtime as I can
luckily it's available to me did she
tell you about it or you found out about
it and confronted her because that's a
cheap thing here
yeah
piranitor
how'd you find it
um I had someone call me wanting us to
um
for refinance our mortgage and they were
going through our credit report and when
he told me how much debt we had I told
him he was wrong because it was fifty
thousand dollars more than what I
thought we had
and then he went through and told me
what it was and
that's when I confront her and she came
clean all right so let me back out let
me pan out just a minute here okay and
then we'll get to what to do tactically
with the money stuff in a little while
okay having done what I do for 30 plus
years
um what we've discovered is is that uh
this is first and foremost a breach of
trust
right
the money is secondary
the primary thing and that's why people
in my world call this financial
infidelity
because it's a deep breach of trust
sexual infidelity is a deep breach of
trust
and truthfully for most people this
activates the same part
in your brain or in your soul that
sexual infidelity activates because it's
first it's not sex as much as it is a
deep breach of trust
right right and so uh I'm telling you
all that and I'm making a big deal about
it not to get her in trouble but I'm
going to strongly suggest you guys see a
marriage counselor
right I think it's probably gonna happen
your wife systematically lied to you for
an extended period of time and she needs
to get that really deep inside of her
she's been a liar a deceiver for an
extended period of time and what that
does to your relationship and what that
does to your trust of her this is not I
bought something at Target and forgot to
tell you
right this is a this is a way different
thing hey can I ask you a question 50
000 is a lot of money which
means there's a lot of items was she
can I just ask was she bringing home
things and you're like hey where did you
get this and she's lying oh it was a
gift did you notice things coming into
the house can can you tell me a little
bit you so unplugged the 50 Grand where
the stuff shows up and you don't realize
it yeah well it's 100 I mean I take full
responsibility for not noticing sooner
um yes she was buying you know baby
stuff but no like big ticket items are
really self any alarms
um but I think she was using it it just
became a crutch for her she was using it
for everyday items groceries she's
wondering for anything she wanted that
was not in the budget the two of you had
agreed to yeah yes yeah whoo
so yeah you guys got some relational
work to do first and foremost okay and
the way a Henry Cloud's got a new book
coming out on trust if it's out already
you need to go get it and both of you
read it because the you were on track
the way you repair trust is first there
is a uh
uh an admission of how big a deal the
trust being broken is
by her and by you
to be honest with you the language
you're using is a little bit soft
pedaling it
you're not owning all of your emotions
in other words
I'm scared it's not like I'm really so
pissed off I can't breathe that's
different than I'm scared
yeah I don't think it's fully hit me
yeah like I said I just found out three
days ago so well I'm glad you're being
nice about it and behaving I don't want
you to do something crazier I mean that
but uh and I don't think this is the end
of your marriage it shouldn't be but she
has to own the fact that she has lied to
her husband
for an extra period of time that's a big
deal and then once she does that then
you say okay we're going to put in place
some systems and some communication
processes with the guidance of our
marriage counselor to rebuild the trust
okay and that is going to be that we
talk a lot about this we talk a lot
about our budget we talk about a lot
about where every dollar is going we
talk about there's you know and you're
going to start pulling the Credit Bureau
report once a month
and um you know we're going to work
through this and pay it off together I
don't mind paying off the 50 Grand but
you've got to have Assurance deep in
your soul that this is not going to
happen or something like this isn't
going to happen again yeah I'm wondering
if something set that off or was this a
behavior that you know that she's always
just been prone to overspending you know
or is this something that's like I'm
freaking out because I'm having a baby
you know what there's not really an
excuse there's there's nothing there's a
line I mean it's just I don't having a
lot of people have babies don't lie it
happens all the time uh lots of people
have husbands that are too tight on the
budget wives that are too tight on the
budget and they still don't have to lie
that's true they just stand up to the
control freak and go uh-huh you need a
little more stuff for the baby put it in
the budget Bubba instead sneaking off
and running up 50 Grand is not okay so
you guys got to work through the
relational part of this and the money
stuff you'll clean up pretty quick
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in hey before
we jump back to the calls let's go uh
back to that subject where a spouse
has lied to their spouse over an
extended period of time about a large
amount of money yeah okay there's lots
of possibilities of things that go on
there
um and so if you're out there listening
um and you're struggling with that let
me tell you the longer it goes on
the bigger the blow up when it comes out
so if you happen to tune in today you
need to go in
trust will be rebuilt faster if you
admit it rather than being discovered
yes number one so that starts the
process and then you need to figure out
what it was that caused you
to want to hide now what can happen is
and I've seen this a lot is it can be
this wasn't the case with that guy or
his wife but what can happen is is one
spouse is doing the bills
the other spouse is just rocking along
yeah has no idea what's going on and the
spouse doing the bills can't figure it
out it's out of control
and in order to keep up the lifestyle
that the other spouse that knows nothing
yes is going on they as a shame based
thing prop up the lifestyle with debt
yep and unbeknownst to the other spouse
so they're propping up the family
lifestyle
another thing that can happen is uh that
that causes this kind of deception most
the time these people are not just liars
yes they result in becoming Liars but
they're not like I get the opportunity
to with malice Screw Up My Life by lying
that's not usually what's going on in
their head so it can be shame based in
that regard another thing that can
happen is they start that you have a
spouse that is a control freak that's
too tight on the budget and their way of
rebelling
is to say well screw you right I'm just
going to go over and get some stuff like
you don't give us enough for food so I'm
going to buy some food yeah I'm taking
matters into my own hands I can ring
this up on a credit card and that way I
they're trying to pull back some control
into their own hands yeah because the
the relationship isn't healthy right
meaning there's no give and take both
votes don't count at the budget
committee meeting so when you're having
a budget committee meeting both votes
count both of you get a say
and you know and and in case of a tie
you got to figure it out that's right
and so uh you're not you know yes I want
to get out of debt really fast yes we're
going to sell intents but no 100 a month
for a family of six is not enough for
food hello okay I mean really well then
there's the scary side of it Dave where
if there's a spouse that's pulled out
their own credit card and they're
spending there could be something even
more ominous at play whether it's an
affair or uh some sort of addiction
problem exactly that's the that's the
third one is they're hiding some other
misbehavior with the financial so it's
not unusual at all I mean because the
the thing we used to laugh about it's
not funny but you know a guy's having an
affair and he's covering all of that
with the credit card over here hidden on
the side because you can't really put
side honey in the budget right right a
light
right right so uh that that you know
that's what you got to figure out so
that ain't you know that doesn't play
either but there's there's so deception
is deception is deception and it can be
that there's something else going on
well the question is okay so we know
Dave
um in the case of gambling in the case
of addiction even some of those other
things those would be the times where
you can put limitations on how you're
combining your money exactly now what at
what point because the call we took
earlier there was fifty thousand dollars
being spent that's a lot of money at
what point would you say okay maybe it's
not addiction maybe it's not something
like that but my spouse is just gone off
the rails at what point would you say
okay there might be a separation of
finance that has to go into it there's a
separation of Finance until trust can be
rebuilt if trust can never be rebuilt
that means the marriage is gone yeah
agree I agree with you uh I mean if
you're dealing with someone who's
recovering uh from an addiction wouldn't
be unusual at all for them to have zero
access to the money for a period of time
and full communication and openness yeah
because that's part of recovering from
the addiction is cutting off the supply
of money to do the addiction and so and
to continue to destroy the family in the
process and violation of that money
thing is also an indication you're back
in the stuff you're back in the
addiction okay you are you falling off
the wagon so uh folks that we don't do
Addiction Counseling here but folks that
do it we work with a lot and they tell
us all the time there's always a money
tie yeah it's always a money type you
cannot be an addict 100 of addicts
eventually have financial trouble well
yeah because something is funding this
you know something yeah something's out
of control and it's always going to show
up in the checkbook and so that's what's
going on so there can be that there can
be it just it could just be simple shame
yeah but whatever it is on your end if
you're the one that's doing the
deceiving a hundred percent of this
stuff is discovered eventually
eventually it's going to come out that's
why it's so much better to just put it
out there look it's so much if you're on
the the negative side of this the
receiving end of it I would feel so much
better if someone came to me and said
here look I made a mistake here's what I
did as opposed to me randomly finding
out about it and having to come to you
and go here's what I found out right
there's a lit a Teensy bit more grace
when that person comes to you yeah well
and there and uh it's easier to begin to
trust again because that's a first
indication of owning it well yeah you
there's got to be some remorse there in
order for them to have done that yeah
right exactly Justin is with us Justin's
in Columbia Tennessee hi Justin welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Jade how are you doing today
great how can we help
so um I'm calling because honestly a
little scared to try not to get stupid
after scared
um my wife and I wrapped a baby step two
right before we moved a couple months
ago our second car was in an accident we
bought a hooptie with the insurance
money that car just failed on us and our
one working vehicle is needing some
repairs and we're struggling with
needing a second car and everything and
um I'm feeling like I'm being moved
towards a personal level and I don't
want to go that route good
okay so what do you get what's your
household income
yeah
um we're about 45 000. okay
all right and you have how much money in
savings
um about 300 we depleted most of the
emergency fund right after we moved with
a couple of things that needed to be
done on our primary vehicles
okay all right so the primary vehicle
needs more repairs
um mostly small things right now the
truth you know we don't want the let
those go and have them become big things
absolutely I want to let them go you're
broke mm-hmm
okay that adds that adds to the drama
when you when you escalate those little
things to make them big things you're
adding to your drama
okay and so you drive one vehicle for a
little while and you work three jobs and
you pile up some money and you go buy
you another hoopty for four thousand
bucks
all right yeah just we're both working
so and thankfully it's at the same place
and they're working with us on the
scheduling and getting back and forth in
one vehicle I mean this is the time
you're going to look back as you say
that time in our life sucked
okay but you're going to make it suck
more if you go back in debt
now Justin you're both working two jobs
and the outcome is forty five thousand
yeah um you're both working we're we're
both working
um at a Chick-fil-A currently because
they were willing to work with both of
us for scheduling
um I was self-employed pre-covered
um trying to work on building that back
up I was a subcontractor for on-site I.T
um you know I was traveling out a couple
hundred miles a day you know how to do
it work and you're working at
Chick-fil-A
um I'm working on catching up on some of
my certifications so I can actually get
into more competitive positions
in the meantime you know how to do stuff
90 of the public doesn't know how to do
yes and that pays more than Chick-fil-A
pays
without the certification there's a
subcontractor most of the companies are
paying equivalent and making me wait a
lot longer for the money the equivalent
to Chick-fil-A
yes
okay uh well I want you doing a whole
bunch of that side work also
and I want you to get your butt in gear
and get your income up because I think
Jade put her finger right on it you guys
aren't making any money I'm not mad at
Chick-fil-A they're wonderful that's not
supposed to be your career job that's
that's true when you know I.T yeah
unless you own the place it's Jesus
chicken part-time job dude I mean if
you're not one of the owners yeah that's
the deal and it's a wonderful place to
have a little part-time job if you're a
teenager right but not feeding a family
with a broken car and
get it
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
Hollow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five today's questions
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services here at Ramsey we
believe in making home ownership a
blessing and not a burden so we
recommend neighborly's network of
service professionals to repair maintain
improve your home this is a great
company
find the help you need at neighborly.com
today all right today's question comes
from Thomas in Nevada he says I hear you
talk about pay for your kids college or
higher education why is this a
requirement I'm not trying to pass off
responsibility I went through college
and paid my way through my parents were
capable of helping me pay for college
but they went through college on their
own and said they learned a lot from
budgeting and needing to control their
spending in order to pay for school I
plan on helping them start out with
books and rent but not planning to fund
their higher education decisions is this
a mental change that I need to make or
are there different amounts that I can
help
um
you know this is an interesting
question and it comes up a lot you know
baby step five if you're listening and
you're not sure about the baby steps
maybe step five is there uh to set aside
money for kids college whether it's a
529 an Esa it comes after investing 15
and it comes before paying off your home
so it's important to know where that
sits in this whole equation and you know
Dave we've never said you know we give
some percentages and some guidelines for
some of the other steps but for this one
we don't say and you know you put ten
percent for college or you you do 700 a
month we don't tell you exactly how much
to put because there is a little bit of
a discussion that goes into this right
um and I think that's the first place I
want to start uh you need to be having a
discussion with your kids regardless
whether you plan on having a full fund
set up for them whether you plan on
matching them dollar for a dollar or
whether you're like hey I don't plan on
contributing anything which I will say I
have questions about that
um but the key is you do need you need
to have those conversations and you need
to have them early because as their
parent it is up to you to help them
understand what that process is it is up
to you to make sure that they're making
a good plan a plan that they can
actually follow through with without
debt I don't think it's a good idea to
just leave them out here flapping in the
breeze and hope for the best and
um I'm kind of going back to my first
thought Dave you know and this is just
coming from Jay talking
I can't imagine not wanting to help them
in some way with college they're my kids
so I might not depending on financial
situations I might not be able to afford
for them to go to Harvard right or
afford for them to go to even the nicest
State School in the area
but I want to help them financially in
some way and I do think that that should
be a goal even if you say okay yeah
we're gonna match you dollar for dollar
I want you working and then we're gonna
put this much in I do think that there
should be a little help there simply
because I mean I'm like I'm your parent
I want to help you out but yeah
paying for college is not a requirement
it's not a requirement they said
requirement and it's not a requirement
it's not a moral thing not an immoral
parent if you don't pay for college I've
often told Single Moms making 25
000 uh that you know we need to teach
that kid how to get um
scholarships yes and how to work and how
to pick a cheap school because they
should just rise up if that's you if
you're a single mom making 25 000 uh
your kid uh you don't have you're not a
bad mom because you didn't pay for their
college absolutely they should just rise
up and call you blessed simply for
feeding their little butts okay so uh
really I mean in that situation that's a
big deal uh now in his case he's able to
pay and then you can start asking the
question so the way I want to ask the
question is this is not what is a
requirement or what is a moral or
ethical it's more back to what you are
saying is okay my job is my moral
requirement is apparent
is to give you uh the tools you need to
succeed in this world that's right brush
your teeth so you have some
that's a good tool to have okay yeah
tell the truth
and you know admitting you lied yeah a
little less punishment but still lots of
punishment because Liars don't Crooks
don't succeed in this world my job is to
grow you into a an adult that will help
you win part of becoming successful as
an adult is to engage in a lifetime of
learning that's right never stop
learning if the last time you read a
book was you're a senior in high school
and you've never done any other training
of any kind since high school you're
probably not succeeding big time oh no
well so and so Dave Thomas started
Wendy's and he was just a high school
graduate yes but Dave Thomas didn't
start and run Wendy's only on a high
school education he was self-taught he
read he learned he grew he was a you
know he was ever he was a lifetime
learner even though he didn't have the
degrees or letters or licenses after his
name but but you know did he build
something the size of Wendy's on the
back of only a high school no he did not
a hundred percent now have I built
Ramsey Solutions based on a four-year
degree and the level of knowledge I got
then absolutely not if I stopped
learning in 1982 when I graduated Ramsey
Ramsay wouldn't be here right absolutely
so a lifetime of learning is your job to
instill in them you're going to be a
reader because leaders are readers
you're going to be engaged in some kind
of learning now then can I
encourage that with some level of help
minimum as you said don't leave them
flapping in the breeze show them how to
do it yes minimum show them how to do it
it is your job to show them how to do it
yeah if you don't want to pay for it
fine but it's your job to show them how
to do it don't expect a 17 year old to
figure this out thank you Dave they
don't have the equipment
okay your job is to go okay here's where
scholarships come from here's where work
comes from teach them to work teach them
to save teach them to budget yeah I'm
for all of that like I've got a friend
that was a professional football player
made bazillion dollars
refused to pay his dad is Blue Collar
refused to pay for his college this guy
refused to pay for a dime of his kids
college
but he showed them exactly how to go do
it in detail
so he upheld that part of it in my case
I showed him exactly how to do it and I
paid for it that's great because I
believe the power of knowledge
not of not of degrees degrees don't have
any power knowledge is the currency yeah
and I believe in that and we paid for
our kids college the other reason we
paid for it is that way we could control
it and help them navigate that process
go to a school you can afford behave
while you're at the school you can
afford and I'm I'm holding a wallet over
the top of your head making you do that
and so you're going to behave or you
we're going to cut this off and they've
got to understand
that debt is not an option because
that's the thing if you if you if you
cut off the money spigot and say it's up
to you it's up to you they've got to
understand the implication of debt
because my coming in my parents told me
all of us all four of us early on you
better be smart or you better be good at
sports because we're not paying yeah and
I'm like okay smart got it got the
scholarship athletic scholarship as well
but I still didn't understand the
implication of debt yep and so I still I
still took out some so no debt pick a
degree that that you can actually make
some money with yeah and go to a school
that's the least expensive and work your
butt off while you're in school I work
40 to 60 hours a week while I was in
college and I didn't die from it I
didn't die from it nobody paying for
mine you probably became a better
student because of it Dave yeah not
really well I think because they say
part time is where you yeah I mean all I
did was work and you know and and but
and anyway it just it wasn't it wasn't
healthy but but uh uh you know I think I
had thirty two hundred dollars in
student loans or something when I came
out but that was a whole nother
different time two issue if I told you
what the tuition was y'all would all
laugh so um but anyway how the heck I
got twenty thirty two hundred dollars in
debt I kind of want to know what it was
possible but the point is you do not
have a moral imperative to pay for your
kids college
you do have a moral imperative to
highlight the importance of knowledge
and show them how to get it and if you
want to help them get it that's okay too
but save up and pay for it and getting
it is not using debt to get it so really
good discussion Jay really good this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Genies with us in New Jersey hi Jeannie
how are you
hi Dave and Jade how are you better than
we deserve what's up
um I need I just need a little bit of
encouragement and some um clarification
on something I heard you say a couple of
um days ago or weeks ago I can't
remember
um I am babysit three I am uh struggling
with getting rid of that last credit
card because I want to buy a house next
year and I do want to do the manual
underwriting but you mentioned something
about
um you're like having a credit card is
more even if you're not using it is more
damaging than not having it
I want my score to be indeterminable but
can that happen if I have a credit card
still open on it no I cannot just tell
me to cut it up cut it up you you cannot
cannot be indeterminable indeterminable
while you have open Credit accounts
anything even if there's zero balances
anything
yes everything has to be completely
closed and zero balance
okay as long as it's open it's still
reporting even if it's reporting a zero
a zero balance
okay I'm already in touch with Churchill
so we're going through stuff but they I
couldn't understand what you how you
explained it before the other day and I
just wanted some
um
the damage is is that what you end up
with when you have one credit card open
and a zero balance and no other credit
accounts of any kind you're going to end
up with a low credit score because you
have almost no credit
that's what it amounts to even though
it's not bad it's just you don't have
any you'll be like a 20 year old or
something that just got their first card
and the only thing they have in their
whole life they're not going to have a
high credit score with One credit card
you know and that's that's back that's
back where you are and that's what
you're setting up so because the
algorithm is based on how you interact
the algorithm that creates the credit
scores based on how you interact with
credit it's not based on anything else
and so if you have zero if you have zero
interaction with credit then that's when
you have an indeterminable a zero credit
score Genie you said you're nervous are
you nervous because you're unsure of
your credit score dropping to zero when
you cut this up are you nervous because
now you won't have this credit card in
your life where's your nerves coming
from specifically I think the nerves are
coming from just having that cushion or
thinking I have a cushion and I don't
want to think that but I just I'm
struggling with myself it's just a
battle it is a battle look I'm going to
validate that because the credit card
companies that's what they tell us they
tell us you can't exist without us you
need us to prop up your life you can't
spend with they've been telling us this
for decades don't leave home without
don't leave home without it and I'm 53
three so I just started this in in
January I'm just like you know I've been
that stuff has been drilled in me a long
time and you're single yes and so you're
you're you feel vulnerable you feel a
little bit vulnerable for that reason
yeah and um yeah that that's very normal
but what that tells us is and it that I
went through this you know spiritually
myself some 30 years ago it tells me
what I'm counting on
what am I what is in a in a sense not
not a true spiritual sense but in a
sense what is my God what is my what is
my provision oh my gosh you know okay
I'm gonna do it y'all it's so good but I
mean it tells that's what I had to cope
with I went who's providing for me I
don't like the way you put that I know
but I I that's what I had to have here
in my head and it wasn't like a golden
calf worshiper I'm not saying that
that's not what you're doing but the
thing is this I I figured out I really
can't count on them to make my life good
I can count on me and my hard work and
my diligence and discipline and wisdom
and I can count on God providing for me
my heavenly father who's crazy about me
I can count on those two things but I
100 can't count on Wells Fargo look
exactly that's a word that's it and
that's that's you know who is my
provider and that's that's what they've
done yeah they've gotten their tentacles
around their claws or around that
portion of our heart yeah that says
don't leave home without don't leave and
that's it turns out Daniel Boone did
he was all right he did okay you know
yeah bankrupt but anyway but yeah
instead of relying on credit and credit
scores I I just said like give yourself
credit give yourself credit that you can
handle your own money give yourself
credit that you can budget and you're a
big girl and a big boy seeing how that
word is interchangeable it is credit as
in I'm gonna go in debt or I'm going to
give myself credit
cred street cred I'm gonna give myself
the belief in myself I'm putting that in
the quick read and that that's what I'm
thinking yeah you know I I there but
that's why the credit cards have big and
the FICO score really when we talk about
this don't worship at the altar of the
great FICO yeah oh great FICO provider
of all good things we bring you
offerings of Interest so that you give
us a bigger score that has nothing to do
with nothing except how much we play
kissy face with a bank and you know we
we really this is our provider yeah oh
FICO good old FICO and I I think of
these bad B movies with like a you know
like a pyramid with flames coming out of
the top and the you know the the the the
you know the the face the face made out
of stone and the smoke coming out the
ears yeah great FICO oh great FICO we
worship you you know like we're Mayans
or something oh my God give me a break
no none of that yeah but I mean that not
picking on her but I mean that's where I
was too I I get it yeah you were
convinced the best way to become wealthy
is to go into that stay in that yeah by
the people who want you to go into debt
and stay in debt yeah they've convinced
us of that the borrower is true really
slow for the lender good hey we another
one's down she's going to cut it up Jade
she is she's going to do it she's going
to do it Kyle's in Spokane hey Kyle
what's up
yes sir I'm happy to speak with you Mr
Ramsey and Mrs walshaw today I have a
quick question my wife and I are on baby
steps four five and six we recently sat
down with a future smart investor Pros
all of whom were excellent good so we've
narrowed it down to two good uh the but
there's one big difference between them
they'd both be great to work with but I
hope to get some guidance one is
strictly fee based they assess one
percent of the account value annually
and that would decrease by a few tenths
as the account increases and value the
second is commissioned base whereas
three and a half percent of all new
money invested in the long term it seems
like the fee based approach would be way
more expensive but he argues that
commission-based guys may use mutual
funds with higher uh maintenance fees to
kind of compensate themselves oh that
would not be true
someone that has Integrity would not do
that so smart investor this morning to
charge you I I buy commission based but
most people do manage funds like you're
talking about the vast majority of our
smart Mister Pros are managed funds are
the one percent plan okay okay the vast
majority of them but there's nothing
there's nothing inherently uh
automatically bad about one or the other
I and you're right technically you will
come out cheaper with the commission
based than the managed base
technically
okay over the scope of your life okay
mathematically but neither one is a
rip-off both are worth the money
and so like uh like I I'm pretty sure
for instance Rachel and Winston have
theirs on the one percent plan and I do
the old-fashioned the old the the
old-fashioned commission plan that's
more of an old-fashioned style okay
but it is cheaper they're called a
shares you're buying a shares and uh the
most you get charged as five and three
quarter on the front end and then
nothing after that nothing ever after
that and so what's it take it takes five
and three quarter years to break even on
that right and so after that you're
making money so 10 years in you you make
but either one or five neither one are
going to keep you from getting rich
having a good financial advisor is going
to make you rich because they're going
to keep you in the game they're going to
have the heart of a teacher and I
wouldn't turn around spit for the
difference I if I were you I wouldn't
pick it based on that I would instead
pick it based on which one of these two
your wife likes best
okay that's good advice right there
which one did she like which one does
she like best
uh it's the the fee based then go with
that
okay she just likes that guy the best
well he is handsome I'll give him that
much oh I didn't mean that oh my gosh oh
my gosh no that's not a reason to pick
him either
otherwise no one would ever listen to my
advice I was about to say Hey you
weren't about to say that I know I was
about to say I know Dave is not talking
about
who can find a virtuous wife for her
worth is far above rubies the heart of
her husband safely trusts her and he
will have no lack of gain
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
what's up guys it's Jade if you love
show and wanted to dive on your
newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pods for
moving in storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade watch
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today our phone number is AAA
825-5225 Jessica is in Las Vegas to
start this hour hi Jessica welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um I think I maybe need some advice
um on our next step me and my husband
are kind of torn he's one way I'm on uh
the other way we have been budgeting for
a long time no like five six years now
but we've always maintained debt uh just
because I know it sounds bad but we can
afford it
um but we're at a place where we don't
want to stay in the in the city that
we've been living in
um for the rest of our lives
um and
he wants to sell the house
uh use the equity you pay off everything
that we have kind of make a fresh start
um rent for a while and then use the
leftover Equity that we have to put as a
saving fund and add to it until we're
ready to probably build a new house
um and use almost everything cash okay
so you're in Vegas you're in Vegas and
you're going to leave Vegas
yeah yeah so our jobs are here in Vegas
but we're looking at probably going to
uh Utah when the commute
there's not a set date okay so why not
do it simultaneous with this whole thing
if you're gonna do that
what was that I said if you're going to
sell the house go to Utah now
okay why wouldn't you do is there a
reason you wouldn't do that she has an
option too yeah I know she doesn't want
to do that I'm just I'm trying to figure
out what they're doing
you know I would love to do that but we
have uh we have one kid and we both our
job we work 48 hours straight and so his
parents watch our child for us when we
when we do go to work and they live just
down the street from us and so you're
not going to Utah
not until his dad retires
and then they would probably pick up and
come with us oh
when is that and so
uh four to five years okay so this is
absolutely bull crap the Utah thing
hasn't got anything to do with you saw
in your house now because four to five
years from now no one knows what's going
to happen and so you're not going to
rent you're not going to sell now and
rent for five years unless you're in a
really desperate pickle how much debt
have you all got and why have you been
struggling with it for five and a half
years
well we just we've just been paying kind
of minimum payments every time just
because how much debt or how much debt
do you have
um we have a HELOC
um and then come on cars and so it's
about 140. 140 on the HELOC
about 70 overall for our vehicles okay
what are you on vehicle number one
uh about 40. okay and what are you on
vehicle number two
around 30 30. you have no other debt
other than two cars in a HELOC in a
house
uh we have one trailer that's about 16
000 and then that's about that's it the
camping trailer of 16 000 bucks
yeah so you've not been struggling with
your budget you've been writing you've
been riding high on cars and enjoying
these cars and and had no ability and no
idea to pay them off what's your
household income
uh we make about 200 a year
what's the what's the note on these cars
car one what's it monthly
just curious what's the monthly payment
on your cars car one and car two I'm
just curious
one is
one is about
one is I think 700 and the other 600.
there it is okay and uh um what's your
house worth
uh probably about
eight to eight hundred and fifty
thousand and what do you all want it
480. okay all right so um do you want me
to do you called and asked I wanna so I
want to double check do you do you want
me to tell you the truth
are you sure
yes okay
I would keep my house
and quit being a couple of two hundred
thousand dollar a year spoiled freaking
brats
and I would pay ten thousand dollars a
month on this debt and be done in 14
months but you guys spend like you're in
Congress you buy anything you want to
buy whenever you want to buy it there is
zero control at this house
okay and you guys have really got a
button down
you're are you 28
yes yeah almost like I've done this
before okay so yeah that that's what I
was gonna that you fit the pattern yeah
I fit the pattern you have you've
excelled in your career and it made you
financially lazy lazy you make too much
money to be this broke yeah that's
called skinny fat
okay
so was that too mean for you
no okay all right you can do this
Jessica you guys you guys are in a
really good position you have a good
life you have good cars you have a good
house you have a good income and yet
you're broke yeah and so you're in a
really good position to get control of
this money monster before it owns you
because one flip of the switch on the
career one flip of the switch the real
estate market and this is going to turn
it on you guys I know it happened to me
when I was exactly your age only I was
dumber than you I had more zeros on it
than you got on it so you guys really
need to get on a written detailed plan
with no eating out no vacations until we
get all this freaking stuff paid off and
or we need to sell all of it yeah not
counting the house yeah what's the deal
with that trailer yeah I think you can
pay it off in 14 months ten thousand
dollars a month that's a you know you
make two hundred thousand you can do
that but this is going to mean you have
no life except getting out of debt but
in a little a year you could be free how
does that sound
it sounds really good would you really
go do it
uh yeah I think we could I think my my
husband's just he's I think he's more on
the it'd be easier if we just sold and
start fresh but it wouldn't change you
it wouldn't change the person in your
house mirror and this process of 14
months of sacrifice y'all are never
going to be the same you're going to be
a different level of maturity than you
ever dreamed of when you come out the
other side of this you got to be careful
with these high incomes I call it skinny
fat because it's that same idea of I've
got this High income and it's an
illusion that I can do what I want it's
like when you're thin and you think you
can eat McDonald's every day and it's
not messing you up because you haven't
put on a bunch of weight but meanwhile
it's messing you up on the inside heart
disease metabolism high cholesterol it's
messing with your metabolism skinny fat
just because it looks healthy and it
looks great doesn't mean that it
actually is You Gotta Do the Right
habits no matter what the situation with
your income yeah you got a real
opportunity here to turn everything
around and keep your house and I think
you'll end up 10 years from now in a
better sleep financially if you do that
than if you just sell the house and
clean off the debt because the debt will
grow back because you didn't change this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
I've got some shocking news for you you
won't believe this Bank of America
accused of opening fake accounts and
charging illegal fees Federal Regulators
said Tuesday they found that Bank of
America harmed customers by double
dipping on fees withholding credit card
rewards and opening fake accounts all of
which are violations of various Consumer
Financial Protection laws yeah because
it's freaking fraud and as a result the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
ordered Bank of America to pay more than
100 million dollars to customers and 90
million dollars in penalties and the
office of the Comptroller of the
currency also ordered Bank of America to
pay 60 million dollars in fines so let
me get this straight 100 million went to
the customers and 150 million went to
the government
some
urges are reminiscent of the Wells Fargo
Scandal last decade that involved
opening millions of bank accounts
without customer authorization the cfpb
said that Bank of America harmed
hundreds of thousands of consumers over
a period of several years and across
multiple product lines and services
among them they found that the bank
which normally charged customers 35
dollars for a transaction that was
declined due to insufficient funds
allowed those fees to be repeatedly
charged for the same transaction
resulting in customers being charged
tens of millions of dollars in fees on
resubmitted transactions they also said
the bank would make special offers of
cash and points when signing up for a
new credit card but that it legal
illegally withheld those promised
bonuses to tens of thousands of
customers never even got your credit
card points and from at least 2012 the
agency said in order to reach now
defunct sales based incentive goals and
boost their evaluations Bank employees
illegally applied for and enrolled
consumers in credit card accounts
without consumers knowledge and
authorization involved using or
obtaining Consumers Credit reports
without their consent and it resulted in
customers being charged unjustified fees
making hits to their credit reports and
having to make efforts to correct the
errors the bank made
someone needs to go to jail
hello
someone needs to go to jail for that
so yeah when Wells Fargo did the same
thing they um it was too it was like it
was crazy it was like I had to look it
up because I couldn't believe that they
laid off like 24
000 people
and it because I couldn't even believe
that but they had like something like a
300 000 people on the payroll it's hard
to get my head around how big these
stinking cabals are they're bigger than
most countries
and they apparently think they make
their own laws
yeah
somebody like an actual actual people
are opening these accounts absolutely
and actual people people are charging
these fees employees yeah yeah yeah in
order to make their own bonuses yeah on
sales incentive goals right I just want
people to understand this is not like a
digital error or it was uh you know
there was no oops there was no oops
involved yeah these are people
doing evil things they're called Crooks
Crooks they're called Banks
and is no one going to jail for this I
don't understand if you rob a bank you
go to jail but if you rob the people you
don't it's like you're allowed to Rob
yeah banks are allowed to rob the people
but people can't Rob the banks this is
how it works
what's going on it just seems unfair oh
man it is unfair Banks can rob the
people but the people can't Rob the
banks explain this to a five-year-old
please okay honey it's called Bank of
America they're bigger than life
okay so Bank of America Wells Fargo
among others the birds of a feather
flock together why would you continue to
do business with a company aside from
all this Malarkey this complete
crookridge going on here why would you
do business with Bank of America to
start with I don't know honestly they
treat you like crap
they don't even know you're there no you
should be doing business with your local
credit union or your small town bank or
at least at the most a regional local
bank
all of Ramsey Solutions all of Dave and
Sharon Ramsey are at banks located in
this area yeah and uh and we don't and
we actually have human beings that we
can call if there is some kind of a
problem
you know and so yeah don't do why would
you do business
with my because I'll tell you why some
of you are there because you opened your
account there and you're too stinking
lazy to move it that's what I'm saying
is right around the corner I can just
you don't want to drive
you got off on direct deposit
your stuff on auto draft and you don't
want to shut it all down and you don't
want to go to the 18 you know maybe
maybe 50 or 100 people you got to
contact re yeah you don't want to go to
all that trouble and so you're still
doing business with Bank of America and
Wells Fargo why that's the only possible
reason I can come up with yeah
and I'm preaching to a
person who used to be a be a member of
the choir myself
don't overdraw
if we can get our overdrafts that might
have saved us let me just tell you it
doesn't matter with these guys
apparently if you just do business with
them they'll pull your credit report and
open an account in your name no that's
true that's the extra shady is that this
is like shade Beyond shade it's shade
Beyond shade uh I'm scared yeah I can't
believe I just can't believe that people
can do this people can't Rob the banks
but the banks can rob the people
this is how it works because no one's
going to jail here no one's going to
and the government got more money than
the customers
I think there's just there's like
there's a lot of crooks involved here
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
got 90 million the office of the
Comptroller got 60 million wow one plus
one is 150 million by the way 90 and 60.
and 100 million went back to the
customers
shoe well I get that you find them and I
guess you probably couldn't figure out
all the money to give to which customers
because it's real complicated when
you're dealing with a crook of this size
um and a monster with this many heads
it's hard to cut them off because
another head growth exactly it's I
wonder what 150 I wonder if 250 million
that's a quarter of a billion did
anything to their stock price with this
announcement
I bet it didn't you don't think so not
much because I mean the profit that they
got was much greater than the cost they
made a lot more than 250 million in all
this crook region that's true man this
is insane they actually got an Roi on
crookridge Wow I'll bet you I'm not
positive but no that makes what you're
saying makes 35 and you know they just
they insufficient and insufficient and
insufficient and insufficient and people
don't pay any attention well that's what
I'm saying people most people don't even
know probably that this was taking place
whether it's because they're not looking
at their bank account statements or
they're not looking at their credit
report to see fraudulent accounts
showing up or something this is just if
you're going to do business with Crooks
you've got to monitor no something
that's the problem with doing business
with Crooks just don't do business with
them in America don't do business with
Wells Fargo I mean don't do business
with these Mega Banks Fifth Third
there's another one
it's the fifth time I've robbed you and
the third time that you've paid for it
oh boy the banks can rob the people but
the people can't Rob the banks this is
how it works that's the moral of the
terrorists that's what comes out of this
that's what I'm getting from it so they
opened fake accounts tens of millions of
dollars in fees on resubmitted uh
transactions that's just on the nsfs
they open Fake accounts and you know how
as big a problem as we have with
identity theft now now you have to worry
about your Banker stealing your identity
earlier in the show they said we
voluntarily reduced overdraft fees and
eliminated all non-sufficient funds fees
in the first half of 2022. like that's
like well thank you very much yeah I'm
like what are you seeing you don't
didn't screw as many people
we screwed fewer people this year than
in other years it's
a release on it and everyone's smiled
right
gosh this is terrible yeah this is
terrible so what's the lesson we've
learned what's the big takeaway Dave
don't do business with mega Banks period
period because you know how many you
know how many times they overdrafted me
none none I don't do business with them
you know how many accounts they opened
in my name none they don't have my
information because I don't do business
with Bank of America I don't do business
with Wells Fargo I don't walk up into
the snake pit and wonder why I got bit
true that
this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
foreign
personality is my co-host today if
you're ever out running around like on
the summer vacation or something or fall
vacation or whatever it is swing by and
see us if you're in the Nashville area
we do this show live from one to four
Central Time on the glass and so you can
come and watch the Ramsay personalities
of the day do the show that day and
Monday through Friday we do that we also
got a wonderful guest Lobby a place you
can kind of go see the history of Ramsey
stuff a bookstore free coffee and
homemade cookies every morning all for
just to say thanks for being our guest
so we've usually got uh 50 to 100 folks
hanging out maybe 200 hanging out eating
or free cookies and watching the show
every day we appreciate you also in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions is the debt
free stage and Janelle and Felipe are
standing on it hey guys how are you good
thanks for having us good to have you
man you're more than welcome so tell me
how much debt have you guys paid off
seventy four thousand eight hundred and
eighty dollars cool where are you guys
from we live in Georgia just
north of Atlanta yeah okay well welcome
to Nashville and how long did it take
you to pay off seventy five thousand it
took us um 16 months 16 yeah yeah good
for you and your range of income during
that time we started at 112 883 and in
2022 into 134 275 in addition to that we
also sold a property okay cool what'd
you say cool uh land in St Thomas
okay and uh where did that land come
from
um probably I invested in okay all right
fun so what did it sell for seventy five
thousand oh okay enough to pay the debt
but I had debt on it no it did not have
debt on it but we didn't pay it off
until towards the end of our journey we
were trying to do it I'm sure you were
almost there okay emergency fund and
yeah and the very end of the payments of
fired very good so what did y'all what
do y'all do for a living
um I work for a prescription benefit
management for hospice and I worked for
a firm that manages a Wastewater plants
and a water plant okay great cool well
good to have you guys very good 16
months you rocked it so uh what got you
guys started on this well um our journey
started in 2017 when we lost everything
in Hurricane Irma we lived in St John
where my husband and the kids are from
and we came here debt-free our whole
marriage had been debt free prior to
that so we had to build from nothing
over the years and after we kind of
relocated and got a house and bought
items shopping sprees lots of them bad
habits were made and then we looked up
and we were 75 000 in debt so that's
that's what got us there and then
through lots of praying and trying to
fix on our own for several years I'm had
been you know looking for some sort of
solution in a friend of ours one day
mentioned you and I was like you need to
tell me more so she did and that was it
yeah so we had a trip plan down to his
brother's wedding and we're like okay
September 1st when we get back from that
trip to St John we are starting we're
cutting up all the cards we're doing
this thing and we did and then we
respond to it yeah we had a rough start
um two weeks into our journey we lost
his brother oh my and then four weeks
later we lost my dad oh my goodness so
we were from Florida to Virginia with a
thousand dollars for the first time in
our savings and nobody could ever
remember and uh somehow we we just kept
our faith and we pulled through and we
never ever used a credit card since
September 1st wow again we had five
prior and they were still active but we
were we were determined and so we did
not we did not use one so when your
friends told you about Dave Ramsey the
Ramsey show what did you get plugged
into was it FPU did you read The Total
Money Makeover like what was that
Catalyst oh she said you need to talk to
Felipe and see if he'll do this with you
you have to do it you know with your
spouse I wasn't board right away I was
sold yeah he said whatever you want to
do honey that's what he is so Financial
Peace University so she said read the
book first okay Turtle Money Makeover
and then do fbu and that's why we did
okay so you did both okay yes very cool
congratulations John yeah very cool
thank you so Felipe you were really
standing there going uh we're in debt I
don't like this oh yeah let's get out
I'm with you let's go absolutely it was
that easy it's a team yeah it's always
been it's the only way it's going to
work amen there's something you guys
said that stood out to me you're like we
moved here we had these bad habits right
but then you said early on you said we
wanted to do it the hard way okay you he
had been talking about we can sell the
lot for a long time and I was like no no
no you know I was like it's going to be
worth more later we need to save hold on
to that it's one of the last things we
had left and then um so we just we were
like we're gonna buckle down and figure
out how to do this and he worked like
100 million hours basically to get us
through the harder Parts he was working
like 78 hours 80 hours a week and then I
was like after several months of that I
realized it wasn't worth missing him in
our life every day working that many
hours in a week and I work from home so
I was there you know able to be with the
kids but then he was never there so then
I was like okay after like 12 13 months
I was like we need to sell the lot okay
you boom and that that both must shown
through babe you should have three then
yes yeah I put this through baby step
three and now we're in four five and six
yeah good for you and you'll never go
back to death
that is a closed chapter you have two
teenagers watching you guys know she's
eight okay that's true
watching you do all this stuff
um
you realize that they watched their
parents become Heroes
it was pretty pretty impressive here too
yeah we preached to him also we yeah and
we preached to him absolutely yeah and
very involved in that process too and
learning how to budget and trying to
teach them so that they never have to
feel that weight of that backpack that
we put down yeah it's it's no way to
live it's no way to live it's a story to
that they'll tell their grandkids every
time at the time that Mom and Dad
changed their family tree dad was
working like 70 hours a week we never
saw him mom said sell the lot yeah
they'll tell their kids that when
they're little grandkids back in the day
yeah
that's exactly how it goes I mean this
is what happens when you change your
family tree it's not just about getting
out of debt because you guys are
permanently reshaped as a family it's
it's a complete new look I mean you had
two horrible losses you got through that
you know you work through this whole
thing you work like crazy hours then you
do this it's very important very well
done it's about wanting to change the
pattern you know yes
exactly you did you reset it congrats
a couple of Heroes very well done what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is you got to believe you
got to believe in yourself you got to
know that your actions today are what
where you're where you are in a year
from now so where you are today is
because of your actions a year ago so
you have to just
stay with it
we talked about it every day we listened
to your podcast every day we cried on
debt-free screams yes and most
importantly as partners go together
listen to each other do it together so
what your friend said was a big deal got
to do it together yeah yeah you got to
talk to Felipe first you got to do it
together yeah because I always handled
all the finances you know and just tried
to buffer a lot you know for for us
because you know through all the
rebuilding we also had to find jobs and
relocate and we didn't have anything I I
she just sends me out to work
run the bacon that's it yeah
I think it's more than that but yeah
it is at least that though yeah yeah
well done you guys very well done okay
the kiddos names in ages Adriana is
eight and Dante is 15. all right very
cool congratulations hey we've got the
live and give box for you the baby steps
millionaires book uh which will come out
and sign at the break and uh that's
where you're headed that's your next
stop for sure we'll be baby steps
millionaires Total Money Makeover book
you can give that away to some friend
that's asking you about it Financial
Peace University another membership to
that and since you've been through you
may want to do it again or you may want
to give it away it's the live and give
so you got to do whatever you want to do
with it thank you for coming to
Nashville from Cummings Georgia to do
your debt free scream we're very proud
of you Felipe and Janelle Dante and
Adriana from Cummings Georgia 75 000
paid off in 16 months making 112 to 134.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
well done well done
man
it is it is so interesting to me that
some people just look in the mirror and
say
I'm changing that's right I did it just
like that I'm changing just like that
I'm trained I'm just gonna decide right
now I'm changing
and their kids will never be the same no
definitely completely changed everything
powerful yes this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host Amanda is in
Baltimore hey Amanda welcome to the
Ramsey Show
thank you for having me sure what's up
so I need some direction here back in
October I got rid of my beater vehicle
because it was costing me too much money
to maintain and I ended up suckering
myself into buying a new vehicle
um two weeks after I bought that vehicle
um I was hit and the driver drove off
which is minor cosmetic damage uh well
it's 1700 bucks for paint so it's not
great
um I don't know where to begin because
Kelley Blue Book before my bin doesn't
have of the book value for my vehicle
since it's a 2023 and then obviously
I'll be upside down and don't know what
to do about that as well as moving
forward to getting us so you're not
having Insurance to fix the car
I do have insurance but I did not want
to place a claim through my insurance at
the time just because my my insurance is
already crazy expensive for the vehicle
so I'm you know with a my car payment's
almost 500 bucks plus 170 for insurance
as it is and I just yeah I didn't want
to go that route 2 000 because you
didn't turn it in
what's that plus two thousand dollars
because you didn't turn it in
insurance is four that's what expensive
is
okay so what kind of car is this
uh it's a Volkswagen Taos it's one of
their newer SUVs
and um what does Kelly Blue Book say
it's worth retail
well so I put in the VIN for it and it
says Kelly Blue Book does not have a
value for your vehicle
so I've looked at comps like other
vehicles in the area near Virginia and
they're going anywhere from 24 to 27 but
obviously with the damage you know take
some off of that yeah and what do you
owe on it they'll be eating them
right around 28.
all right you have any money
no no
savings I have like a thousand like a
thousand yeah no okay
just a thousand bucks how bad is your
credit
actually who's your loan with
um
uh hunkins
yeah just you got it at the car dealer
I did yeah nine percent it was right
what during the microchip microchip
shortage and I was looking at used cars
and they were marked up and I was like
well might as well buy now yeah yeah and
then I have the guilt and regret with
that so
I'm sorry
um
what do you make a year
um with everything combined 84
how much other debt have you got
just my house
why don't you pay why don't you pay
three thousand dollars a month and be
done in 10 months
keep it
hey how much 3 000 a month
no life I can't afford that no life yeah
you can if you quit eating out and going
on vacations to stop your 401k
I don't even have money going to that
then you need to get on a budget and
find out exactly where your money is
going
how much is your tax refund
I owed last year
um
yeah I mean 3 000 a month will get you
out in 10 months
that's 36 000 out of 84 000.
I
[Music]
a month do you have kids so my kids told
my kids so my take home sorry that's not
that's not take home those taxes coming
out a lot
I know 84.
but you don't you don't have 25 000 tax
bill so something's wrong what else is
coming out of your check
my mortgage my oh your mortgage comes
out of that your mortgage comes out
before you get home
okay
so five thousand is sixty thousand a
year
84 000 from sixty thousand is twenty
four thousand you do not have a twenty
four thousand dollar tax bill I do not
know where your money's going
you do not get taxed twenty four
thousand dollars on an eighty four
thousand dollar income
it's not so part of that is child
support is obviously adding that in and
then so if you consider 68 minus taxes
that's where I'm at for just the income
straight from work
you're you're paying child support
no it's I'd receive she's receiving it
additionally
that's where I was coming up with that
number but that yeah the from work alone
it's just how much is your house payment
okay that's not out of control if I were
you I would get on as tight a budget as
possible pick up some extra income and
just pay this car off
okay you don't think it's worth trying
to nope Sala didn't take a loan out on a
cheaper vehicle nope
doesn't solve the problem
so um unless you just hate the car
anyway uh not not hate not hate not hate
the regret that it represents but hate
the actual vehicle sure then um yeah
it's kind of a piece of junk oh is it
yeah but you're gonna have to go okay
here's the thing if you go borrow four
thousand bucks and you sell the car and
you write a check for four thousand
dollars then you borrow another four
thousand or five thousand dollars and
get you a used car uh your ten thousand
dollars in debt give or take instead of
twenty eight thousand dollars in debt
and you're going to pay that off very
very fast and then you're going to save
up and buy a better car that's a that's
another route you can go but you got to
cover the amount that you're upside down
which is somewhere around 4K and you got
to go buy a five six thousand dollar car
for cash so we're gonna have about ten
thousand dollar debt over the credit
union
to pull this deal are there
for those types of loans I mean I've
looked at a couple of the like I've
looked into a few different loans and
some of them have different rates based
on what they're using them for are there
certain types of loans they should be
looking at you should be looking at a
small town bank or credit union just be
looking at a loan because your credit is
good you make eighty four thousand
dollars a year they should loan you ten
thousand bucks it's not that big a deal
the rate doesn't matter because I want
you to pay this off by Christmas
right right they want to be done with
yes
you got to play all the way through and
clear this mess up and then then save up
and move up in car to a better vehicle a
twenty thousand dollar vehicle is not
out of line for you if you pay cash for
it and do better research and slow down
and don't fall victim to the chip
Marketplace or the used car Marketplace
all of that was bull crap in your ears
and you believed it enough to go buy
some impulse thing and so you've learned
your lesson on that never to do that
again but you are going to rein you're
going to get back into approximately a
twenty thousand dollar car when the
story's over that you've paid cash for
but you need to step all the way down to
six thousand maximum budget for the car
that's your maximum budget and then
you're going to drive that for about a
year while you save up the money to pay
cash and move up and that's what I would
do in this situation but
um
but if you love the car and you want to
keep it and just roll up your sleeves
tighten up your budget and lean in and
clean the mess up she does not love that
car I think for her that is a reminder
of a dumb moment in time yeah I've had
I've had stuff in my driveway that I was
paying payments on stupid and paying
payments on stupid is painful yeah I've
done it it's just like every time you
write the check it just yells at you yes
it's stupid I hate it man iron rings in
my ears I I've paid so much stupid tax
in my life it's unbelievable I mean
these dumb things I've done I heard Dr
John deloney talk about it's another
book and I'm not going to be able to
remember what it's called but it's about
the idea that your things speak to you
every time you walk by them and so when
you have that car in the driveway or
those things every time you walk by them
they're yelling something at you and if
you use debt to get them hey they're not
yelling nice work they're not yelling
it's explicative nice words
my car says nice words to me Yes mine
does too it says I'm paid off yeah
I was bought in cash mine says don't get
another ticket
oh that's that's funny
slow down
oh that's funny that's good yeah hey
he's right though your stuff talking it
reminds you of bad times or good times
and
um you know it's one of the reasons we
get attached to things yeah is that
right there so that's fun you're gonna
get through it Amanda if that's the
dumbest thing you ever did you're a
smart person right you're a smart person
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phone is a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Eunice starts off this hour in
Philadelphia hi Eunice how are you
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
until I'm on my husband he's only 50
years old and he was residing to your
retire
um she's only 50 years old
so he's only 50 years old
the money
okay what does he do what does he do
he's
um in it he's a computer programmer okay
why does he want to retire at 50.
uh he thinks he's ready
I think she's ready
I think he wants to join the Fire
movement
um the fire movement so that is
financially independent uh retire early
which a lot of people are into now for
anybody who doesn't know and it's this
idea of having a certain amount set
aside I mean it's it's a retirement plan
but it's all about retiring early okay
so retiring early would presuppose that
you hate your job
okay I'm 62. I was just talking to
somebody a while ago I do not plan to
retire ever
and I've got millions of dollars you
know why because I love doing this
I'm going to come on here so long that I
don't make sense anymore
does he plan once you get to another
field okay then he's not retiring he's
changing careers
yeah but there's no guaranteeing income
there's no guarantee on income on
anything
is he going into business for himself is
that what it is
he wants to manage our finances
that's his career
Well your desk why he wants to move into
so how much money do you guys have
what's your net worth
um our net worth is about I just checked
this
about a supreme point eight
I'm sorry 800 000. oh 3.3.8 million
dollars okay yeah it does not a
full-bound job diminish 3.8 million
dollars
that's what I'm saying not even close
it's not even a part-time job
unless you're going to do something
really really stupid that's what I'm
about to say he's gonna start doing some
day trading and some yeah we're going to
play crypto we're gonna play a bunch of
gambling stuff no thank you okay yeah
you do have the right to want this to
not happen gamble but yeah he wants to I
guess he's fired in the corporate world
and so he wants to try doing something
else and
you're saying about seven different
things so I think what's the problem is
is there's no Clarity there's a lot of
ambivalence and ambivalence always
causes anxiety so he says retire you
here quit and blow all our money then he
says retire and he means he wants to
start a different career an encore
career which by the way is perfectly
fine he might make more doing that than
he makes now he says he's sick of
corporate America well that's easy to
get so I completely agree with that so
he wants to start his own gig doing uh
whatever I don't care sitting on my butt
and calling 3.8 million my full-time job
and wrong answer sitting on my butt
period and living off of the income from
3.8 million highly highly unsatisfactory
as a life he will be depressed in 24
months
people who do not do things for other
people of and just sit on their butt and
consume are not happy people Hedonism
has never had a good end to it
yeah I I guess um I wasn't so clear
um retiring from his corporate job
quitting his corporate job to do
something else awesome I'm in yes you've
got 3.8 million dollars you've got
nothing to be afraid of quitting is and
move on to another job yes but quitting
his corporate job and doing nothing
or calling managing 3.8 million a
full-time job those aren't true those
aren't good plans they're not good life
plans no much less financially
Eunice are you still working
I am working but I don't earn as much as
him what does he earn yeah
parents 150 plus bonus okay I only
earned half of that okay so I think you
guys need to sit down and say what I'm
really concerned about is is that you do
something
not for the money well that's what he's
assuring me he's assuring me that he's
doing something
the opportunity cost is
if you don't need money you got plenty
of money
you're not going to go hungry
3.8 million or 10 380 000 a year without
touching the principal you don't need
money have you guys paid off all your
debt
well uh we do have about 300 uh uh debt
on two properties
um but that is being rented so the rent
is being done off yeah
yeah so what you guys have not done is
you've not the two of you need to sit
down with the television off and spend a
Saturday planning and talking about what
it is he is going to do next
nothing is not on the list
time
um he feels that that's more rewarding
than one than what he's doing right now
it sounds like he's not sure because
we've heard corporate we've heard
managed financing we've heard teach yeah
well well that's why he's saying that
he's going to keep himself busy by
teaching at the same time managing our
finances
but he wants to leave his corporate job
okay
I I think I'm going to give him advice
but I'm but it's dangerous because I'm
not sure I have a good clear picture
having you have enough money to not have
to work
not working not doing anything or
dumbing down your career and calling
that satisfying is not going to work for
you
getting out of corporate America awesome
teaching part-time and making fifteen
thousand dollars a year and calling that
fulfilling is absolute BS this guy's a
guy he's wired with more with more
electricity than that that's going to
get really really boring he could
already be teaching part-time if you
really wanted to do that and he's going
to figure that out but he's going to
learn it the hard way yeah he really
needs to find something to lay his hand
to this idea that I'm going to go I had
a friend of mine sold his business for
15 million he was 31 years old and he
said I'm going fishing
after two years after two years he was
very fat it's all that fish fishing all
he did was fish and drink beer and he
hated himself and he went and opened
another business and has had three
different careers since then and made
that much more money again but you can't
sit on the boat and fish and drink beer
it doesn't work this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phone's a triple eight eight two five
five two two five
so um
as a person of faith
I look at this money thing through the
lens of a Biblical method of living
now you don't have to and you and I can
be friends but that's what I do and so I
love the quote when it comes to
financial Independence
that Bob gas said
the guy from the Northeast a preacher
old Pentecostal preacher guy he said the
definition of prosperity
is having the money to do God's will in
your life
yes so if you are living on the mission
field and
a third world country
it doesn't take a lot of money to pull
that off you don't need 300 000 a year
and if that if you're living on the
mission field and if that's God's will
for your life let's just let's assume it
is
and you've got the the mission work is
funded where your family can eat you
have reasonable safety reasonable
shelter while you're doing the mission
work but you're in a situation where it
doesn't require a lot of money to do end
quotes God's will for your life
then you are prosperous
you are very prosperous by definition
if you are called to
uh run some massive thing it might be
millions and millions of dollars to run
so that that's that's God's will he's
asking you to do that
and so the way one of the things I do
around here is I judge the stuff we do
at Ramsey okay is this project this
thing we're getting ready to launch this
new brand this new effort this new
whatever is that God's will is he
willing to do it and one of the ways we
can ascertain that is if we have the
money to do it that's right if we don't
have the money to do it then it must not
be at least not yet because apparently
he owns all the money and so if he wants
that done
wants me to do it put on it won't be
Bank of America that's funding it I sure
hope not it'll be it'll be the money
will be here and it won't show up
mysteriously he'll give us the way to
make the profit to do it yeah might show
up mysteriously but that's so it happens
very rare and that's why they call it
Miracle because it's seldom yeah and I
haven't really lived my life for a
miracle to Miracle I've lived my life
from production to production but God
gave me two hands of Mind a work ethic
energy
yeah you Boundless Energy to work pray
like it all depends on God work like it
all depends on you exactly and so
um
you know when you're talking about
financial Independence
you need to think about independent from
what
because I've never I I believe in
becoming wealthy but I don't know if you
ever really become independent
as a matter of fact you might become
more dependent because I'm convinced the
more stuff you own the more repairman
you have to know I mean you're you're
more interdependent the bigger your
footprint is Mo Money Mo Problems yeah
yeah it is in that sense or more
responsibility yeah for sure you know
and so more you know and you see things
you never saw before you feel a
responsibility towards uh folk that that
are struggling that you never felt
before because you're able to to do
something about it and
um so you know
I I don't know much about this fire
movement but if it if it has to do with
I want to pile up a bunch of money so I
don't have to do anything yes then
that's the exact opposite of what we
teach it's all tied into that minimal
Monday I don't want to work it's all
tied together in that if you hate your
job and that that's where you should
change jobs that's where the Crux is you
should go to Ken coleman.com and get a
different job get something do work that
has meaning yeah because if you hit your
job of course you want it I'm gonna work
15 years of my life and completely burn
the candle at both ends or something I
hate with people I hate in a toxic
environment to pile up enough cash to
escape when I could have just quit yeah
and I mean these people with the fire
movement their sacrifice I mean the
amount that they're putting into
Investments I mean they're living on a
quarter of their income they're putting
so much it it's okay but I'm saying you
know after before you retire you're not
gonna get free no you don't get free
this out of Heaven I mean you don't get
free you you all you do is you're going
to move from one thing to the next thing
is all and so this idea I'm going to be
independent now you can be independent
of having to work for a jerk yes but
that requires keeping your lifestyle low
and your assets up and I think really
the Crux of that is when you when we
talk about this all the time when you
become debt free it does change the way
you work because you're no longer
working simply because you have to pay
bills simply because you have to prop up
a lifestyle you start to decide what you
really enjoy doing what you'd really
like to spend your time doing what you
what matters to you putting your effort
towards and that is something that I
think is very Noble
um as opposed to just saying I don't
want to work anymore right yeah I I so I
can get I can come alongside sacrificing
to win I can come alongside piling up a
big old pile of assets
uh prospering yep I can come alongside
becoming successful financially I'll you
know to the extent you want to do that
you got me on your team you got the
Ramsay folks on your team but I will
tell you as an old guy you're not going
to become independent
you're going to discover it's quite the
opposite that you're more interdependent
than ever before you cannot Escape if
you're not the Unabomber and even he
didn't Escape okay so you you really
aren't you know this this mythology I'm
going to pile up a bunch of cash and
move to Costa Rica and nobody's ever
going to see me again yeah but you have
no humans in your life right that know
you and love you where's your family
where's your friends where's your
history you're just going to go live in
a foreign country where no one knows who
you are all by your lonesome self that's
called mental illness
okay I mean really human beings need
long deep gratifying relationships and
wealth is not to escape from that it's
to embrace that it's very good and to
accentuate that and so this idea that
you're somehow going to be independent
that you're not going to have to have
any problems or any people to deal with
it's quite the opposite let me tell you
what wealth does a hundred percent of
the time it magnifies you
it makes you more of what you already
are
so if you're kind
you're going to become unbelievably kind
if you're a generous person you're going
to become what we call a philanthropist
if you are have a problem with anger God
help the people in your life if you get
money
God help them
if you are a crook and you get money
you're going to do crook on steroids man
you gonna do it whatever you do you get
money you're gonna do it big you want to
know what but there's part of that too
with this retirement thing because if
you are that person if you're a generous
person if you have a servant heart if
you are a person who loves helping up
it's going to be hard for you to not
work well because you're going to want
to do more you're going to want to do
more yeah so in other words I'll I get a
whole lot more personal spiritual
emotional mental health satisfaction out
of doing the show out of meeting someone
two couples who just paid off their
house at the break right I get more out
of that than I do income yeah yeah
there's no income that offsets that
meaning so if you cannot Escape man's
need for meaning that's right uh Victor
Frankel's book Man's Search for meaning
I read it 25 years ago and I just read
it again the other day uh and it was
like it was brand new it was long enough
long enough ago that I read it that I
think I forgot the whole thing but uh
Man's Search for meaning but it doesn't
come in a pile of assets no so you're
not going to get enough assets to not
have a need to produce something for the
good of others that is that is innate in
you it is part of your DNA you do not
get to escape Society because of wealth
quite the opposite quite the opposite so
don't look for financial Independence
look for some Financial Security not
pure security there's no way you get
enough to ever be 100 secure
but uh but but you know but but look for
I'm gonna have an uh where I don't have
to worry about the money for a bag of
Doritos right I mean right I don't have
to worry about that one less thing and
you know I look for some security look
for the ability to change your family
tree look for the ability to be
unreasonably generous look for the
ability for your wealth to create enough
income that you don't have to work
that's right you want to then work
anyway yes doing something
wow I didn't even thought about that
stuff in a while yeah this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you like this show you
can help us we would appreciate the help
subscribe
follow
leave a five-star review
share the show click the share button or
share the link or tell someone when and
where you're listening or watching and
they can join the way you are or another
way we are on virtually every platform
that is imaginable and we're there for
you so check us out and help us out by
spreading the word Please Subscribe and
follow this makes a huge difference in
the algorithm and the uh different
Services letting other people know that
we exist on the debt-free stage in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions John and Alex
are with us hey guys how are you
fantastic welcome where do y'all live
Oklahoma City cool welcome to Nashville
and how much debt of you two paid off we
paid off 156 971 excellent how long did
this take 18 months good for you and
your range of income during that year
and a half we started at 107 000 and we
ended at 235 000. wow
up in 18 months what in the world
um how do you go up 135 000 in income
both new jobs
um I got a promotion within yeah and uh
quite a few side hustles wow amazing
what do you all do for a living I'm a
project manager for electric company
here in Oklahoma City and I'm an
insurance agent ah very good okay so
just uh hustle and grime baby yeah get
her down then it says
um side hustles and overtime what was
the most lucrative side Hustle
I did
a tree delivery Cruise shipped
we both did doordash
um I mowed lawns probably the most
exciting one was I got to sing for a
local Ballet Company wow yeah so that
was cool that was very cool yeah it
wasn't it wasn't too much but it was
still that's cool still fun yeah
remember again they paid yeah it's good
yeah fun and paid fun good and what kind
of debt was 157 000 everything it was uh
car loans student loans personal loans
credit cards medical bills I mean all
the all the bad choices wow how long you
all been married almost seven years okay
all right and 18 months ago two years
ago or so something happened what
happened
um well I was really just like what you
were talking about I just got really
comfy in a job that I hated and decided
to leave he told me you know he realized
how much I hated my job and
um you know gave me the question where
do you see yourself in five years
and I would that was just like a really
eye-opening moment for me and I got a
new job
um our starting income was before I got
that new job and
um
you know if you have a job you liked
more that paid more yes a lot more
that's the way it's supposed to work and
then what happened was that
um he was just a little too relaxed
about me relieved relieved thank you
relieved about meeting getting a new job
and I was just like what's this about
like are we okay
um and I I was just like why are you so
relieved about getting a couple hundred
dollars extra a month and that's when he
whenever we started talking about oh he
showed you the budget there yeah so
there was underlying you were already
having underlying stress about the money
well I budget or lack thereof got it he
told me the other day every time every
time I watched the the office
um that part where he declares
bankruptcy
he's so stressed about it bankruptcy
that's not how it works
he was so stressed about it and I was
just like and we weren't talking about
it at the time and so
um he was going to man up and carry it
yeah it wasn't working though yeah and
so we finally kind of we were just like
well we're we're both in debt like so
much money we might as well do something
about it and then I I feel like I
finally convinced him that
um you know
we can do this we can pay this off this
is how we do it thank you
I've been I've been an on and off
listener up until that point for the
last probably like 10 years so we were
hovering in the midst exactly so he knew
that you guys had a problem and needed
to solve it and you were like I think I
have the solution yes cool cool cool and
was that so it was listening to the show
did you get plugged into FPU we
um I found a
um a certified coach or a Ramsey coach
thank you shout out to chance Jackson
with extra label Financial way to go
chance we had monthly
um coaching sessions through Zoom we did
them on our lunch break
and
um he really just showed us that we can
do this and
um you know we we told we told them that
this is the goal the being here and
coming to see Uncle Dave hey I have a
question of this debt how much of it was
student loans oh
almost 60. see I want anybody listening
to hear that because so many people
think they can't pay it off 60 000 of
student loans and we paid we were so we
sold the how we sold our house and we at
the very end
um and we used the equity because we got
quite a bit of equity from it
um and used it the last what was it 46
46 000 to pay it off and that was the
same day that they said that they kind
of declared that no student loan
repayment yeah sure just kidding on that
forgiveness thing psych yeah you got
your vote gotcha we were already
planning on doing that but you know
we're taking this in our matters into
our own hands paying off our debt we had
a plan
um actually because we knew you know
Congress doesn't bet a thousand so we
knew that they weren't it wasn't going
to happen so we were going to kind of do
but it's in the wrong way yeah uh what
we were gonna do was I wasn't able to
make my last 10 thousand dollars because
they had forgiven it and it wasn't there
but I couldn't get a paid in full letter
they wouldn't send it oh wow so what we
did was we were prepared to put that
back so as soon as the balance was
available it was there already ah okay
very good perfect timing well done good
job guys how's it feel to be free
amazing yep more than anything else you
feel like you got control now yeah we do
and now you're working together because
you weren't before nope you get out of
bad habits that's um you know Thomas
Soules said that today's problems are
awesome all usually a result of
yesterday's Solutions so so when you
come in and say well I'll just put that
on a credit card I'll just get a loan
I'll do whatever no because now it's
today's problem
wow amazing well done you two all right
now that you're experts you did it you
actually did it it's not a theory what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is
work together just talk about it work
together get out of the the victim
mentality or the victim of of situation
like what you talk about in your baby
steps millionaire book
um that that chapter really hit hard
with me I think it's chapter five yeah
and and don't be afraid to to talk to
your to your husband your wife your
spouse whoever because
they're not going to be as hard on you
as you are on yourself about it yeah so
there's a lot of
um fear that you know they're going to
be so disappointed they're going to be
upset they are but not any more than you
are with yourself and also just believe
that you can do it like just just
knowing that you can do it and keep your
keep your goal in mind like my goal was
to not have to
you know I would have to probably have
to work this hard later on in life but I
did if I didn't do this right now I'm
gonna have to work this just as hard
later on in Life or more or more and I'm
missing I'd be missing out on on my
kiddos stuff all because I'm working
yeah
congratulations you guys we're very
proud of y'all hey we've got another
copy of baby stuff's millionaires for
you another copy of Total Money Makeover
for you Financial Peace University uh
the live and give box and you can uh
either keep all of it or give it away
whatever you want to do that's your our
gift to you for coming over from
Oklahoma City to do your debt free
scream John and Alex Oklahoma City 157
000 paid off in 18 months count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
yeah there we go that's how you do it
you gotta love it yes
yeah and you're watching this or
listening to this and it's my turn to
tell you it's your turn yeah you you're
supposed to be doing this stuff right
now this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture of the day Ephesians 5 15
and 16 so then be careful how you walk
not as unwise people but as wise making
the most of your time because the days
are evil
Thomas Edison said having a vision for
what you want is not enough Vision
Without execution is hallucination
facts
I think that one that is great oh my
goodness Jim is with us Jim is in
Seattle hi Jim welcome to the Ramsey
Show
oh man thank you for uh taking my call
uh first time caller can't thank you
enough I appreciate you wow thank you
how can we help
okay um through uh quite a quite a list
of what I have
um one of my main things is uh funding
baby steps so
my uh my nervousness my uh scared my
stress level is uh is all high I'm not
through a divorce yet we're we sold our
house of 17 years last year
we uh again divorce is not final but um
we initially each got 50 000 to find new
housing I'm renting right now good
um my question is I have 40K in the bank
when the divorce is finalized
uh 40 plus in the bank uh right now just
sitting in my bank
um when the divorce is final I'll I'll
have 235 ish maybe Plus on top of that
it's funding the baby steps uh versus I
feel like I need all of that based on my
income to put the max down for my next
home wherever I'm going to live I said I
was renting right now so I really want
another house and be a homeowner
just not sure which direction okay and
you were married uh 20 years
22. I'm sorry I'm sorry you're going
through three it's you know I mean it's
it's horrible yeah it is three kids 20
almost 22 19 and 15 and a half and so
the 15 and a half year old my daughter
back and forth week on week off we had
temporary temporary orders when we were
living together and we're just waiting
on mediation and trying to sort it all
out I'm hoping soon yeah
okay
um
you should buy a home
but not until you've
let the um
cobwebs
clear from your mind because you are
grieving a death
yeah I understand so it's okay for you
to rent for a little bit because if you
bought a home in the next six or eight
ten months or whatever you'll buy a
different home a year and a half after
that
so I did thank you Dave I did sign a
two-year lease so my timing of
everything I'm nervous about that too
where I am relaxing you don't need to be
you don't need to be nervous
my lease is September of 24. I feel like
I can't make a mistake leading up to
when I'm going to be out of my rental
that I'm in now well you've got a year
and a half to worry about that
and you got a lot of bigger fish to fry
during that year and a half
yes so just chill
you can as you notice there's an
apartment on every corner and you can go
get you another one year lease somewhere
even if you have to jump but you give
yourself uh emotional margin
to make a wise purchase instead of a
instead of feeling like I have to rush
and go buy a house there's nothing to be
nervous about there's always going to be
houses in Seattle
and I know you know where I live in the
area uh I'm paying you know looking for
it was tough to find a place you know
I'm by myself single income now and
trying to even rent a place that wants
three times the rent I don't make that
much money it seemed impossible to even
find a place and it became very
fortunate to be where I'm at now but
it's just crazy the prices which will so
many people have to deal with I
understand but um I am fortunate to be
where I'm at I'm going to use it to heal
I just want that finalization from the
divorce so we can yeah I agree you do
need to have that and you don't need to
be buying something until that's final
for sure but even a little while after
that just give yourself a little time to
just cry and a little time to just heal
and then you'll make a wise purchase at
that point you'll have 200 something
thousand to put down plus or minus being
debt free plus or minus having your
uh your three to six month emergency
fund in place that's right yeah that's
sad that's tough 22 years is a long time
yeah and I love that advice to just slow
down and because what you said is true
what you do in those first few months is
radically different than what you would
do to two years from now a year from now
yeah it's just it's a
it's the same is true if you lose a
spouse yeah yeah I mean it you're it's I
mean obviously it's a different scenario
but
um and a different kind of pain but it's
still making big personal financial
decisions while in pain is not
recommended you're not thinking straight
and none of us would be none of us would
be I told Sharon if she leaves I'm going
with her well I also think in those
divorce situations
I also think in those situations of
divorce when there's kids involved you
know there's this rush to get a sense of
home quickly yeah you know to kind of
like okay like let me make sure I get a
place where everybody feels like they
can come I have them you know on every
other weekend I want to make sure they
feel at home and you know I get that but
uh taking that time is important yeah
Michael's in Cincinnati Michael what's
up
um how are you doing today Dave great
man how can we help
um so me and my wife we are 22 years old
we just got married last year she's
graduated college in December
um so now we're having twenty five
thousand dollars of student loans
um we're in the process of saving up for
a vehicle with the intentions of paying
cash next year and starting a family
um do I work to pay those student loans
off now instead of saving for the
vehicle or do I pay the payment
um which they're not due until October
but obviously we are starting now
um getting paid off sooner and keep
saving for the vehicle or what do you
suggest I'd take it one thing at a time
and I would start with the debt I'm
assuming you both have vehicles now
right that the other vehicle would just
be an upgrade
yes ma'am to your family vehicle yes
yeah I would focus on paying off this
debt how much do you guys earn
um I did 62 000 last year gross uh we'll
do about 130 this year combined okay so
you can pay this off in a year less
that's gross yeah yeah
and I mean we have our three-month um
emergency fund we have about 12 Grand in
emergency fund and I mean we both have
retirements going we have a Roth IRA and
what not that I invest in so so if you
really wanted to clear this quickly if
you really wanted to clear this quickly
you would walk through the steps and
you'd take that 12K down to 1K throw
that at the student loans and then cash
flow the rest you can pay this off stop
adding to your retirement temporary yeah
that's right temporarily it's only going
to be a couple of months but you're
going to get that how what percentage
are you investing yeah well he's gone
doesn't matter that's all right whatever
your five percent seven percent all
that's going back into your cash flow so
you can that's more money that you're
throwing at this debt you guys are going
to be done with this in a couple of
months yeah if you focus on it if you
don't you're going to keep it around
like a pet right and that's the problem
with student loans people think they're
harmless but they
um they grow up and take over the house
share our people Dave that with 25 000
of student loan debt that are waiting
20 years to have it paid off by the
government
and they're going to be so disappointed
they're going to be so disappointed
disappointed yeah because keeping it
around as a pet when they could have it
done in six months seven months nine
months the people who just did their
debt free screen paid off what was it
eighty thousand
in 18 months yeah having the government
run your financial plan is like going to
the DMV for efficiency
I mean this is just this is the wrong
place to place your hope it's the wrong
place on inept incompetent and crooked
people oh my gosh people that will say
anything to get your vote and had no
intention of doing it at all no um so I
mean I don't want you to pay anything
the fastest way for you guys to get
financial stability and start hitting
your goals and build wealth is to get
out of debt and stay out of debt that's
why we're telling you that so
um we would tell you to knock out the
debt and we just did as fast as you
possibly can and then build your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and then save up and pay cash
for your upgrade car and you got plenty
of time to do all of that that's right
that puts us hour of the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]